wir sind noch lange nicht durch durch
diese pandemie ist sind ganz viele
menschen noch nicht geimpft die sind man
nicht auf der sicheren seite
es ist für alle anstrengend sich an
diese regeln zu halten es ist
anstrengend masken zu tragen das weiß
ich auch aber ich sage ihnen das ist
eine frage der solidarität dass wir
jetzt auf den letzten metern alle
solidarisch bleiben das heißt auch
diensten auch die genesenen und dazu
gehört ellbogen begrüßung maske tragen
und das schaffen wir jetzt als land auch
noch dh blume für sie auch noch keine
zeit zur rückkehr zum handschlag wir
leben auch in den deutschen großstädten
in einigen clustern dass die indische
variante sich beginnt deutlich
auszubreiten und in großbritannien sind
die insolvenzen trotz seines großen
fortschritt auch über die 50 wieder
gesprungen
bei corona darf man nicht alles jetzt
fahren lassen ich bin froh über alle
schritte zur normalität die wir erreicht
haben
und natürlich kann man manche fragen
noch diskutieren werden die auch auf den
tisch kommen in den nächsten tagen
stichwort masken pflicht seminar
öffentlichen raum aber ich kann nur
davor warnen jetzt so zu tun als sei
corona schon vorbei wir haben's ein paar
mal erlebt dass wir uns zu früh bei
corona gefreut haben und dass ein
die einfachsten mittel die aha regeln
inklusive machten pflicht ich halte die
für die geringste zumutung und einen
sehr guten schutz nach wie vor